oh wait you're Gucci huh
[Music]
here
The Exchange present for the Christmas
party you know since we skipped out on
it oh so what do you say we trade them
all right
here
[Music]
what's inside they're gloves I made them
myself my mom wrapped them for me
ah wow this works out nicely if you play
games in this wind your hands will go
numb yeah true but if I play with gloves
on I can't play as well I won't have any
freedom it's better than your fingers
getting stiff from the cold yeah huh hey
you're really red are you okay oh am I
hahaha
you have a fever
and it's finally winter break
it'll go to waste now that you've caught
a cold
I'm fine
[Music]